desde que Rusia comenzó a atacar a
Ucrania con esos drones chajido kamikaz
del pasado octubre la preocupación de
las unidades móviles que se crearon para
derribar ese tipo de objetos es que
muchas veces en la oscuridad no los
pueden ver por eso han pedido el apoyo
no solamente del ejército sino también
de los voluntarios de crear alternativas
para poder identificar esos objetos en
ciudades Como kiev por ejemplo muchas
veces en la noche hay tanto ruido que
ellos no pueden oírlo Así que este tipo
de reflectores ayudarán a identificarlos
incluso con mucha más anticipación
uno en sus grupos va a ir a casi un
kilómetro de aquí y estará con unidades
para medir la intensidad de la luz
cuando oscurezca apuntaré las luces en
su dirección
es más efectivo usar el porque los
integrantes de las unidades móviles de
defensa antiaérea pueden ver el objetivo
si no usamos luces cada hombre de la
unidad tiene que tener su equipo de
visión nocturna por donde viene el dron
el uso de los reflectores nos ahorra
recursos y dinero
los reflectores no solo estarán
alrededor de los ríos hay diferentes
unidades móviles de defensa que se
sitúan en diversos lugares propicios
para enviar los drones como bosques o el
campo abierto además de los ríos y Polar
lo que hacen esta noche los voluntarios
En compañía del ejército es probar
diferentes reflectores que alcanzan
diferentes distancias y así luego
trabajar en conjunto con las compañías
que los producen y crear el receptor
realmente necesario para esas unidades
móviles que trabajan en el campo